Привет! Сегодня мы говорим про PRD. Собираем всё, что мы наработали за весь модуль, в единый документ.
PRD — это Product Requirements Document или в продуктовых компаниях его обычно пишет Product Manager.
Дизайнеры его читают, иногда комментируют, редко пишут сами. Зачем вам уметь это делать?
Тут есть две причины. Первая — это защита. Без PRD решения принимаются устно. Мы же обсуждали,
что тут будет по-другому, я думал, ты понял, это не то, что я имел в виду и так далее.
PRD фиксирует договорённости. Что делаем? Для кого? Зачем? В какой последовательности?
Когда через месяц кто-то скажет: "Давайте добавим ещё вот это", вы открываете PRD и показываете:
"Вот скоуп, вот что осознанно отложили и вот почему". Второе — это ценность. Дизайнер,
который приходит с макетом — просто исполнитель. Дизайнер, который приходит с PRD и макетом — уже
партнёр. Он понимает продукт на уровне стратегии, а не только на уровне пикселей.
Это уже другой grade и другие деньги. У нас неоднократно это подтверждалось на реальных проектах в студии.
Первое — это Executive Summary. Одна минута, чтобы понять суть. Самое главное — коротко о продукте.
Затем у нас цели и метрики. ОКР. Персоны — для кого всё это мы делаем. Конкурентный ландшафт — что у нас уже
сейчас есть на рынке. MVP scope — что делаем мы. User Stories — конкретные требования с критериями приёмки. И roadmap — что будем делать потом.
Всё это у нас уже есть. За восемь уроков мы собрали каждый кусок. Brief, Research, Audit, Persona,
интервью, приоритизация, Scope. Perdi — это сборка всего этого дела. Агент читает все файлы и собирает документы.
Но мы сделаем не просто какой-то документ в доке или вот здесь вот MD-файлик. Мы соберём его полноценно в Notion.
Ну как мы? Это за нас, как обычно, сделает агент. Это будет документ, которым приятно пользоваться и можно будет
шарить ссылкой. Смотрите. Ну, я как обычно для вас собрал директиву, которая уже собрана по документации
Notion с полным пониманием того, как это всё дело переносить туда. Но прежде чем
в Notion что-то переносить, нам нужно этот Notion подключить. Смотрите.
если вы действуете так же, как я, через расширение Клод, то мы заходим на сайт именно Клода.
Здесь заходим в Customize, Connectors, тут нажимаем на плюсик, Browse Connectors и находим здесь Notion.
У меня он уже установлен, поэтому мне это делать не нужно.
Если ты пользуешься именно Antigravity и встроенными моделями, то открываешь, как ни странно, Antigravity,
именно вот этот свой чатик, правую панельку. И здесь у нас есть:
тут у нас MCP-сервера и здесь и списка этих MCP-серверов можно искать.
Обрати внимание, что тут на огромное количество приложений и сервисов есть MCP-сервера.
Это может быть тебе полезным. Тут, конечно, тоже пишем Notion,
подключаем, после чего входим в свой аккаунт и на этом настройка завершена.
Он уже будет понимать, в какой конкретно Notion нужно всю информацию выгружать.
Итак, директивы, как обычно, делают все за один запуск.
Я, чтобы под запись не ждать, как видишь, уже ее запустил.
Он тут описал кратко, что сделал и сразу дает нам ссылку на PRD-документацию в Notion.
Здесь в Notion я нажимаю share, опубликовать и у нас страничка в вебе полноценная создается.
Давай на нее перейдем и посмотрим, что у нас здесь есть в документации.
Итак, первое, что видим - заголовок, иконка, оглавление.
Ну, тут и так все понятно.
Видим, что у нас тут executive summary, цели и метрики, OKR, целевая аудитория, конкурентный ландшафт,
MVPscope, story, нефункциональные требования, риски, roadmap.
В общем, все то, что у нас было в структуре прописано.
Кликаем по любой секции оглавления и переходим к конкретному блоку.
Как видишь, здесь все расписано: Northstar метрики, OKR, целевая аудитория.
Вот три наших персоны: какая из них primary, какая secondary, конкурентный ландшафт.
Какие именно возможности мы предоставляем, какие из них являются основными.
Чем мы вообще отстраиваемся от рынка.
Далее у нас MVP scope, что нужно сделать.
Все сделано также через чекбоксы.
Что у нас осознанно не в MVP, но планируется в следующих итерациях.
И конкретно в какой именно.
User Stories у нас вынесены в отдельную базу.
Мы еще посмотрим на нее нефункциональные требования, риски, открытые вопросы.
И краткий roadmap, разбитый по версиям, фокусу, что основным является в этой версии.
И ключевые фичи, которые нужно здесь реализовать.
Также тут у нас две таблички.
Первый из них User Stories.
Это сторики наших персон.
Здесь также размечены теги.
Что это за персоны, статусы можем отмечать.
Также есть доска по приоритизации.
Ну тут, как видим, у нас все в приоритете must.
Это можно уже самостоятельно раскидывать, добавлять новые.
Также можем открыть.
И тут у нас, например, как Антон, я хочу видеть, на сколько дней хватит баланса.
И тут критерии приемки этой истории.
Что нам нужно выполнить, чтобы удовлетворить это требование.
Также вернемся обратно по хлебным крошкам.
Тут у нас есть фичер roadmap.
И также тут все фичи, которые нам нужно реализовать, расписаны.
Разделены по тегам по приоритетности и по версии, в которой они будут выпущены.
Вот, например, перейдем в roadmap table.
И здесь видим.
Вот список того, что нужно реализовать в MVP.
У него priority must, соответственно.
И краткое описание того, что же это за фича.
Вот у нас первая итерация, версия 1.1, 2.0 и вообще в backlog.
Итак, по итогам этого модуля, что у нас есть.
Brief, конкурентный анализ, аудит, персоны, интервью, приоритизация, scope и PRD.
По сути, этот PRD - это только верхушка айсберга.
Главное, чего мы добились, это выстроили агентскую среду с вообще полным контекстом по нашему проекту.
После чего мы можем дорабатывать бесконечно, переиспользовать все полученные знания, расширять их и решать вообще любые задачи, связанные с этим продуктом.
Финальным заданием будет подключить Notion MCP, точно так же создать PRD при помощи директивы и при сдаче домашнего задания прикрепить ссылку на опубликованную версию твоей документации.
На этом все, модуль по исследованиям закончен.
На этом все, модуль по исследованиям мы закончили, собрали огромную базу знаний, огромную базу директив, чтобы в дальнейших своих проектах ее переиспользовать.
Мы прошли путь от размытого запроса в три строчки до полноценного документа и вообще огромной среды, базы знаний по нашему продукту.
С этим всем уже можно начинать проектировать, этим мы и займемся в следующем модуле.
Удачи с выполнением домашней работы, до встречи!